to Ian Neal for a substantial extensive
and Innovative lens designs which have
had a lasting impact in Motion Picture
cinematography the academy presents him
with a Gordon e Sawyer award Ian come on
up and get your Oscar
[Music]
[Applause]
come on
okay well I have three ways to do this
three ways to speak there's something up
there I can just about see with my
implants in my eyes and then I can try
to remember a few words and I can also
try to read the few words so probably
mix them all up together
um I gotta say you know obviously why
this is this is amazing so it's uh you
know it's really something
you know it's a great honor you know to
receive this award and firstly I'd like
to thank the academy
the Board of Governors site Tech
committees
you know for this award
since I come from a Baker's family in
Glasgow Scotland you probably saw the
The Kilt earlier
a few times but I've I've reduced to
just the waistcoat
tonight
um so so because I'm coming from a
Baker's family I will um I won't give
this award a number I think you probably
guessed the number it was actually I
didn't realize when I mentioned numbers
but so we just call it a baker's dozen
you've probably heard this saying and he
said because because I don't want to
have an unlucky number you know
secondly I think if I were to start
naming people I've known over many years
that might take a while and of course I
wouldn't want to miss anyone out
so I'll limit the naming to my family
starting with my parents who cannot be
here but drove my career quite a bit and
of course they were fundamental to me
standing here tonight
and my lovely wife Stella and my son
Andrew they're here over here
in the audience
well I would say they've surely reached
a point of lens saturation maybe that's
what I call it almost as great as my own
um and yet they still put up with my
never-ending appetite for sunny lens
design
in other words I'm still doing it even
now
I have to say that
you know over the decades I work with so
many people who've all been involved in
various areas of City lens design and
development
you know and I have to say I've you know
I've enjoyed working with them and
there's been a lot of ups and downs some
of these zoom lenses were
I would see a little bit nerve-wracking
not just technically but for the people
funding them
in fact there was one lens I I won't
mention the name but there was one well
I'll say it's a zoom lens and it was one
of the earlier ones it was eight years
to develop the lens to actually develop
it and have a product and there were a
lot of you know digits in front of the
the million dollars it was a very
expensive project
um and anyway
now I've stood up here before
um of course and I've always wondered
you know what else to say
um so I thought maybe um I mentioned a
little anecdote way back to when I first
got into the movie business I think they
mentioned I work in other areas so I
actually came from um I'll use the word
surveillance business
just to be careful uh with the wording
um surveillance
still do actually work in that area and
um
so so coming to Hollywood well I had an
interview
it's the only company I'll mention
actually I had an interview at
Panavision who are developing their
latest pre uh Prime cine lenses I think
they were shown here Primo Primo cine
lenses and but the company Panavision
they had a they had eyes on developing
companion high-end I mean really
high-end zoom lenses in fact they
actually had to match that the prime
lenses which going back we're going back
about 35 years now to try to have a zoom
lens we're talking about technically now
technically match up prime lens is
especially a very good prime lens is
quite difficult it was quite difficult
so of course I was asked during my
interview you know could I develop these
zoom lenses and
um you know I'd done I'd done a lot of
previous work before actually in the
surveillance area surveillance field but
it was all infrared zoom lenses you know
like for thermal imaging you know the
night time and heat looking at Heat
uh so of course I was um you know I was
aware about zoom lenses but the question
was you know you know could I design
the lenses that Panavision wanted and
um you know I sort of thought about it a
little bit and thought well
probably not really but you know I've
got you know I want to get the job
you're not Panavision so so I I just
said you know you know to hit with it
the answer's got to be yes you know so I
said yes
the funny thing is though after I
started working on the zoom lens project
and and many others afterwards I
realized that this is all Cutting Edge
state of the art uh lens work you know
lens design work and and it's all
Innovative so actually no one's ever
designed them before anyway
so then I thought well you know the
answer was true you know yeah I mean I
may as well have said yes because
what difference is it going to make
and and I got the job and after like I
mentioned earlier like eight years and a
lot of money
the company did end up with its first
really high-end zoom lens and then I
think at the end here they mentioned the
Primo micro Zoom actually I think it was
Curtis Clark mentioned that oh it was
the shot with the um Minority Report
with the shutdown on the lady's eye you
know the drawback shot that was a whole
at the time well I guess even today it
was quite complicated with zooming and
focusing and a crane and you know
computer and
so so so anyway
um
anyway that's how I got the job at
Panavision and um no one did really know
that I couldn't design the zoom lens
when I got the job but I got the job so
one other thing I thought I'd mention
was just um
you know today a lot of people asked if
I was just asked outside the theater
actually the these uh I guess press
people you know and this keeps coming up
now and and I hear about all this
digital stuff and computers and farms
and whatever it is
um so so I'm often asked well what's the
difference between cine lenses of 40
years ago and City lenses now I mean
it's just cine lenses right
I said well the difference is back then
everything was shot in film at least you
know mostly you know predominantly shot
in the film nowadays it's a lot of it
most of it's Digital Imaging and that's
actually changed the look of the image
so you've got the new technology you
know you know digital digital cameras
electronic sensors as opposed to film
and the trouble with if you just take an
old film lens and stick it on a digital
camera uh well there's a problem with
digital imaging and that is the picture
doesn't look very good it certainly
doesn't look like film
um so so so
you know I hear the words like well if
you shoot with a digital camera the
image looks you know sort of sterile
clinical and it's not uh it's not
aesthetically pleasing
so we're so so we're faced with a
situation here where it's a sort of a
dilemma where the new lenses the modern
lenses have to somehow make the digital
image look like the film image because
of course the point of all this is not
really technical at the end of the day
it becomes you know it's an artistic
thing you're trying to create a look a
certain look to the image
so you know so there's several there's a
few ways to do this I'll just I'll just
glance on this because of the time
restriction
um I just mentioned you can use old
vintage lenses and I mean old vintage
lenses
um and put them on the digital camera
because these old lenses are not they
don't perform very well but actually
helps it sort of mushes up the image a
little bit and makes it look more like
film you can take existing lenses and
sort of you know get a hammer and a
chisel and sort of bang them around and
take a little lens element out and
forget to put it back in that that kind
of thing
um that's called Deep tuning by the way
that's the technical term detuning
nobody talks about the hammer
um and sometimes the hammer can destroy
the lens but you know what the heck you
get the image you know
uh the last option is you actually
design brand new lenses and of course I
like doing that that's my favorite
approach because that get that that
gives me a lot of work and I still work
keeps me busy and of course uh you know
my family they're fine putting up with
it because they've been doing it for 40
years you know so so it gives me lots of
work to do
another thing just jumping on another
thing about City lenses that I found the
best way to design them
is actually to go to the film sets or
you know location whatever to actually
be there with the production because you
really need to talk to the artists and I
don't just mean the cinematographer you
know you've you've various people and
you can even be directors producers
actors who a visual special effects
um but you you because you really need
to know what they want
so you have to understand what they want
from the lens it's not a matter of
Designing a lens and saying there you go
guys you know
shoot Terminator 23 you know it doesn't
work that way so and it's not just
computers numbers so you've got to have
a strong connection with the artist at
least that's the way I think of it and
um actually it makes the lens design you
know maybe I'm pushing this a little bit
but I see it's a bit of an art in the
science it's sort of a combination
because if you only make it a science
it's uh it's a nice technical device but
you know does it really work for the
person using it
um certainly nice in the computer when I
look at the screen and I look at all the
numbers but is it good to use
so so the point is that even with the
migration from film to digital
um you know the desired look the look
you know the look of course it varies
you know depending on the storyline Etc
the desired look is always it's always
been uh it's always been the same really
and lenses are a great tool for getting
a favorite look
just before ending I would like to say
something I've been
quoted on many times
it's just a little side fight but um
it's interesting to note that camera
technology including film
and digital imaging capture hasn't you
know it will change over the years you
know it obviously changes
um but but the you know all that all of
that Imaging system still depends on or
relies on one image forming uh device
the lens
and
um actually the lens predated film
um I'm not going to go back to Leonardo
da Vinci or who came up with it but it
went back a long way and I guess it will
probably Outlast current silicon
Electronics which is what's driving
sensors for digital cameras so the lens
has been here sort of before film after
before what we know now is digital
cinema and probably it'll it'll be here
later with some new kind of digital
cinema or something different so to
finish I'd like to say
um I think it's marvelous that the
academy has almost prom has always
promoted the scientific Technical
Community as you know as a whole with
lens designers being you know over the
years they've been recognized for cine
lens work
by their peers I think this is highly
motivating for up-and-coming lens
designers definitely promotes what I
call the Art and Science of lens design
again I thank the academy for this most
special golden award thank you thank you
very much
[Music]